[Musique]
combien d'espèces fauniques sont
menacées ou vulnérables au québec
38 il y a tout d'abord celles qui sont
en voie d'extinction
québec les désigne comme étant menacée
il y en a 20 il s'agit du carcajou du
caribou des bois de gaspésie ou du
béluga du saint-laurent pour ne nommer
que les mammifères
s'ajoutent à cela des poissons comme le
chevalier cuivré des reptiles comme la
tortue mouchetée ou des oiseaux comme le
pic à tête rouge les espèces qui sont un
peu moins mal en point sont désignés
comme étant vulnérables
il y en a 18 on parle par exemple de
l'ours blanc du faucon pèlerin de la
tortue des bois ou de la rainette faux
grillon de l'ouest
enfin il y à 118 espèces qui sont
susceptibles d'être désignées
vulnérables ou menacées
cette catégorie regroupe entre autres
des poissons des oiseaux des insectes ou
des mammifères quant aux cougars son
statut n'a pas été révisé depuis 2006 il
se retrouve donc toujours dans la
catégorie des espèces susceptibles
d'être désignées vulnérables ou menacées